les enfants ça rit ça tousse sa place et
sa revendique et tout ça parfois dans la
même minute pour mani soleymanlou part
d'un garçon de 6 ans et comédien dans la
série
sur livre à ses enfants la vie familiale
n'est pas toujours rose bonbon
la vie est devenue de plus en plus
pressantes des choses les horaires sont
devenus de plus en plus exigeants de
travail ne quitte pas des mains parce
qu'on est sur nos téléphones depuis
malgré tout je pense assez raymond qu'à
un moment donné il faut tirer la plogue
la série survivre à ces enfants met en
scène trois jeunes couples d'amis
apprivoisant au jour le jour la vie
familiale
l'auteur jean françois léger qui a
travaillé entre autres sur les émissions
un gars une fille et les parents a écrit
ici une autofiction l'inspiration vient
beaucoup de mes quatre enfants jeudi
toujours à la blague ça a été l erreur
de ma vie mais que j'essaye de la
rentabiliser en vampirisant mes enfants
pour mettre leurs vies à la télévision
cette série de 13 épisodes a pris des
allures de catharsis pour la comédienne
catherine bérubé mère d'une fille de 5
ans c'est un peu spécial parce qu'elle
est ni ce personnage qui me reste à
ongles et j'aime bien tristement
beaucoup je pense qu'à vos avons avalé
chercher des corps j'ai beaucoup de
survivre à ses enfants à bord de ces
moments d'anxiété pour tout parent de
jongler avec le travail
héritage familial tout en s'occupant de
ses enfants et de son couple du monde a
toujours servi à dédramatiser les
situations durant notre vie ça
certainement notre conseil de dire
utiliser lumeau parce qu'on finit par
passer au travail chez les enfants sion
qui nous apprend comment être des
parents
on commence comme ça j'ai appris à être
un père c'est mon fils qui m'a appris et
on inverse je présentais cinéma c'est du
film un mois si la puissance dix marins
on pourra voir survivre à ces enfants
dès le 22 juin sur ici tout point tv ici
mais radio-canada